foreign
Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
[Music]
hello hello
yeah welcome to Lifeline you guys
welcome back for another rip roaring
episode you know what I mean we're
recording yeah we are recording and I
will be and when does this come out
Sunday oh dude I will be in Seattle
tonight
chrysalia.com and I will be in uh Rhode
Island and New York and San Antonio and
Sugarland Texas
chrysalia.com oh I'll be in Jacksonville
and Lakeland Florida and also Daytona
Florida so go to chrisley.com to get
those tickets and uh that's that's that
you're gonna put the thing on the screen
here so you can talk about the thing
I'm being so vague just saying you want
to go uh uh you got a question click the
link below or go to lifeline.com
a watch
lifelines.com well there's a space in
the [__] watch space Lifeline space
and the other thing is you know
underlined but uh that's okay
hyperlinked hyperlinked yeah one-on-one
advice you want one in one advice yeah
maybe people do yeah if they do they
should go to mattelier.com and book a
session with me
matalia there you go get yourself out of
a hole Yeah out of a conundrum the whole
get her outer whatever you need and then
we got that we talk about it we got the
great Lifeline merch is at Lifeline it's
at lifelinemers.com
um so yeah that's it dude sorry dude
sorry sorry we just said that but we
have to pay some bills you know what I
mean
we're gonna pay some bills that's what
they say on the radio we'll be right
back we got to pay some bills yeah yeah
and then they go to the commercials hey
do you know anything about the death of
Casey Kasem
no I know I I I guess I just I knew he
died I guess anyway I knew he died too
but apparently there's some Scandal the
true like the some mystery about his
death why but like someone I don't know
but here's the thing every time I open
YouTube it's it's a suggested video I'm
Casey occasion the mystery of Casey
Kasem's death and well I don't click it
oh well but I think about it all the
time so I'm always like well just click
it whenever I think
um see I looked yeah no I looked on
Wikipedia
and there's something that happened
that's fishy How I died
I'm Casey Kasem and I'm dying of an
illness I think but it might be because
it's something else was it uh number
five what was he on
what was he on uh the radio oh oh really
yeah but what I'll say Scooby-Doo what
do you mean Scooby-Doo what did he do
for Scooby-Doo he was the voice of
Shaggy he was yeah I'm Casey Casey I'm
coming in at number three wrongful death
wait
I I don't I I don't know
oh wow wow I'm Shaggy coming in at
number five I'm Shaggy dude
[Laughter]
dude isn't it weird that we used to
listen to him do like the top yeah 100
greatest whatever coming into number 10
it wasn't me from Shaggy
and it wasn't me I died and it wasn't me
somebody did it well the worst song
title of all time I'm Casey gajam why
are you doing look you just got out of
the dentist someone killed me
coming in at number three someone killed
me
no no one killed him it's like his
family something about his family yeah
coming in at number six something about
my family
okay that's really cool um so yes in
case of kid well no I didn't know about
that but I'll have to look into it you
know I have to do my research maybe have
some answers for me next time I ask yeah
I will
um so yeah anyway but yeah
what is that noise
oh someone upstairs dude um my uh my son
got his big boy bed just today he got
his big boy bed and it's really cute
cute you know what it's really cute it's
cute dude and he likes it he wasn't sure
because he had the crib with the wall
off of it you know he just kind of could
crawl into his own crib we had three
sides you know what I'm talking about
like a Christmas it is but you take the
the side off and it makes it like it's a
nice transition into a bigger bed
I got rid of that because I got another
baby I got the other baby coming and the
other baby's gonna sleep in the crib now
and then we're gonna put the wall back
up on that thing and then he's got his
big boy bed and they came today so what
does the what what do you know about the
second baby so far it's a boy
and he's coming is it named no we don't
know the name yet okay yeah uh we have
ideas but we don't know yeah what do you
think the name should be drop the names
in the cup drop it in the comments
you know what I mean so [__] YouTubey
you guys what do you think the name of
my new baby should be dropping in the
comments I'll pick I'll pick the one
I'll pick the best one
hey your name is lightning rod
um do you want to tell everybody what
mom wanted to name one of us she wanted
to name me Thaddeus that's the one I was
thinking of yeah dude coming in at
number one no dude Thaddeus what would
they call me Tad worse no Thad Thad
worse sad dude Tad no it's Tad is the
nickname for Chad she said she would
have called you Thad
dude that has a lisp talking about
emotions and I'm I'm Thad my son is Thad
I'm Thad nice to meet you yeah oh it's
gonna be okay I'm Thad nice to meet you
see ya
wow someone driving away because my name
is Dad um yeah I do it so if your name
is Thaddeus I'm sorry how different
would your life be if your name was well
I'll tell you what I went to I would
have went to full school I would have
went to [__] as much school as
possible I would have because I got some
sort of degree and I would be [__] do
I would be honestly I would do mounds of
cocaine whoa mounds of cocaine if my
name was Thaddeus I feel like if you're
thaddies you need to be in Academia
somehow
there's like a professor so loads and
loads of school massive amounts of
cocaine professors don't do cocaine okay
so that's where you're wrong because I
would be the professor that does do
cocaine and I would do mounds and mounds
of it and Scarface will be my favorite
movie and A Beautiful Mind those those
both of those movies will be my favorite
movies for different reasons and then I
would do mounds of cocaine I've been
thinking about this dude I should
probably start doing cocaine you
mentioned that which is weird why do you
say that also I first of all no you
shouldn't I need to okay second of all
why do you say that I need to get I need
a go-getter attitude I need to get up
and just go let's do this because I
don't do that okay how about other
things first like
I mean I don't know many many things
like going to bed at the right time and
wake up early okay I'll get on this what
is it circadian rhythms get on a cycle
dude your sleep's all [__] up you wake
up at 11 A.M sometimes yeah but that's
because I do like shows and it's late
and then I come home and it's one and
then I go to sleep at like 2 30 because
I'm [__] jacked and I have to watch
like an episode of you know what I mean
can kill thy neighbor and so it's like
to wind down though you know what I'm
saying
no you should just go straight to bed
when you get home and they do it I'll
toss and turn I've tried to do that if I
do that I'll stay up till five because
I'm just like this waiting and bored so
I have to like wind down maybe even
watch like some South Park or something
like that if I want some yucks but like
I you know it's
what do you think that you should do you
said Adderall but that's like I didn't
say Adderall you did what you said
earlier someone else said I don't know
okay so someone said Adderall but it's
like I don't want to get better than
cocaine I don't want to get hooked on
something though then why are you gonna
do cocaine I feel like I'm not a roll I
couldn't take it because it's a
prescription cocaine I feel like I could
do it because because here's the other
thing too when I do when I do cocaine it
and I've never done it but when I do it
I want to make sure people know I do it
and I want to have the powder all over
my face all the time I can't stand
watching people do during shows you
don't have to see me do it but I want
you to see like the smear and be like yo
what's up everybody how you doing like
doing my shows me like he's not cool
so you know people on cocaine are the
most of all the drugs yeah like being
around people on different drugs people
on cocaine are the most annoying and
I've been around many people on like
ecstasy which are also so annoying but
it's not even close cooking it's just
like you you make me anxious when you're
on true yeah I do I don't like her I
Don't Like Cocaine there's a lot of
people who do okay and I've never done
cocaine and people honestly think I'm
always on cocaine anyway I can't imagine
if I was on cocaine I'd probably be able
to float
uh like or do magic or something I mean
people are like this guy's coked out of
his gourd all the time I told you about
the [__] that [__] that happened to
me yep yeah yeah
yeah
people think I look so much like I do
cocaine they come up to me and ask me if
I have cocaine and when I say no
inevitably because I never do because
that's one drug I've never done they
look at me cockeyed and they think I'm
like lying oh you've never done cocaine
no I've never I didn't know that okay uh
but what about the thing when you went
to go get your surgery remember I
thought that's what you were going to
talk about
what remember when the doctor was like
yeah we have to talk about your cocaine
problem oh yeah yeah my nose I've talked
about that on this yeah you have
actually never mind but yeah my septum
was so deviated my sinuses were so
[__] up that my doctor had like a sit
down with me yeah and like uh what do
you call it like like he had uh
brochures and [__] about how to get off
cooking right I felt like a liar because
I was just like I look I know how it's
gonna sound right everyone that you
approach like this says this but I've
actually never even come back in once in
my life that's so funny dude well uh
whatever you know at least that you're
in good health and you don't do cocaine
I look like I do cocaine on the outside
and the inside apparently right that's
the morals so why you've never done
cocaine
I don't like people on cocaine the first
reason is that interesting second reason
is I have like a weird visceral disgust
reaction to people snorting powders oh
really I've got I've snorted powders
what have you started I was in something
where I had to act like I was uh snoring
cocaine what was it like a movie thing I
understand what was the thing you were
snorting oh uh I don't know actually so
whatever it is such an idiot I did ask
but it was a long time ago but you know
this you do you like you'd get the prop
stuff yeah and I snorted it and
sometimes it's just baking soda
sometimes it's okay to do it baking soda
because of cornstarch well whatever it
was I did it and I didn't get high yeah
no [__] but I was still worried because
I was I was like well I get high I've
never done drugs and they're like
there's no drugs in this I was like okay
I remember you used to get worried that
you would get contact high from being
around people who were smoking weed
right well well yeah but you can though
not really dude
inside like a really tight space and
they need to be blowing smoke into your
orifices really yeah did you just HotBox
in a [__] like bedroom and people are
smoking you can't get a contact high
my whole thing is if you're going to do
drugs do the drugs that don't
[__]
smell and like
you know what I mean get in my clothes
weed is the worst no weed is not really
a drug weed is for everybody but that's
fine though but I don't want it to be
all like in my face plumes of smoke it's
like vaping is the worst so get people
to do smoking out of mind for some
reason get people to do Edibles around
you right right way better way better
carry Edibles okay before they light
their [__] say no no here you go yeah is
it legal to carry around Edibles yes is
it okay it is even if you don't have a
license you don't need a license dude
you don't this is California
California's weed is like I could go get
weed right now without a card you could
go into any store not without a card ID
only I thought there were cards that you
had to have nope not that was years and
that's the old way hell yeah dude we're
making progress yeah with the program
maybe I should just go to one of the
stores get the weed Can it can do they
sell brownies they do right yeah oh [__]
man or maybe I want to smoke that loud
though you want to smoke now no I'm just
I don't want to I'm just saying if I'm
outside and I'm outside of the place and
I get it and I light up and I just smoke
the sticky icky might be nice it might
be nice but you've never smoked weed
have you no never no I should probably
eat it you're right but here's the
[__] about eating weed okay I want
to eat uh
I want to eat more than just a little
piece of a brownie brownies are [__]
awesome I agree but here's the thing
that is weird I'll I have such a high
tolerance sound I'm so used to that I
can eat any well-made edible and not
taste the weed then the person that I'm
with will be like really and taste it
and they'll like spit it out they'll be
like this is [__] disgusting I don't
I for some reason I guess it's because
I've had so many of them I don't taste
the wheat in it anymore I only taste the
the sweet thing or the yeah whatever I
mean sometimes it's not chocolate but
why don't Everyone likes more brownies
is what I'm saying why don't they just
spread the weed out and make it a little
bit like more you know what I'm saying
and then this way you could have two
three brownies because I think you get
equally as high with just one bite
because I think with Edibles you just
want to get high you don't want an
entire [__] brownie
but this is not for brownie lovers it's
for weed lovers do you know what I'm
saying uh tolerate it going down if you
want a brownie you get it right oh I
guess too you could eat just like one
little bit of weed brownies but then
also regular brownies yes you could do
that you could totally do I wanna get
high
so high so nasal so nasal be real like
some of my Instagram posts anyway let's
go with that be real that's Cypress Hill
yeah nice he'd like us on my Instagram
post this one doesn't matter right now
it's fine but I wanna again
so high
okay okay so let's go to the first first
thing
here we go
what's up boys uh this is Drayton from
Atlanta Drayden love y'all out here
um keep doing what you're doing my
question today is uh hey hey uh let me
finish oh that's exactly what my
question is
when people are interrupting you
schizophrenic and you just keep losing
your thoughts and yours what you're
saying because they keep interrupting
you and you just don't want to be rude
about it and say hey shut the [__] up I
was just talking it's the worst but you
you want to be able to say what you want
to say and these people are always
interrupting you yeah my question is how
do you deal with these difficult people
dude appreciate it you know how I do you
need to get a noops button at
chrisley.com you go there and you just
hit it oops because they interrupted you
you say look at this man we made a
mistake here this is not how the
conversation is supposed to go and I'm
willing to accept my part in it but like
you interrupted me maybe I gave you some
maybe I gave you like a hint that I
needed some help with this conversation
but I don't dude what the [__] you're
interrupting me there's different kinds
of people that do this though and it
there's like tears okay of terribleness
right okay the tears of terribleness so
chicks is one who's the the tears the
tears of terribleness you ready yeah
tears of terrible that's the very top of
the wrestling Squad the highest tier of
terribleness is Hulk Hogan with the
black monster person that interrupts you
because they they think they know what
you're going to say and they start like
saying it with you or telling you that I
get it and I'm going to finish it for
you that's the worst you're the worst I
have to stop doing this so you're the
worst but I'm I'm thinking about it and
then at the bottom is just like
people who interject with questions
that don't realize their questions will
be answered by the time I'm done so so
now I think that's the worst that's the
most innocent no that's fine okay it's
innocent you're right that's the most
innocent that's the most fine it's
annoying but it's the least terrible so
I'm gonna get to that I go like that if
you're just keep listening you'll see
that you don't need to ask that question
yeah that you can do that you can also
you can do whatever you want though the
truth is you don't have you don't have
to be nice to those people because those
people aren't being nice to you they're
interrupting you for whatever reason
that's rude yeah so you can say anything
from like wait did you want did you want
me to tell the story or did you did you
just want to talk that the most [__]
back like so angry doing that I do that
yeah that's good that's good did you
want just so much darkness in you in
there yeah did you want did you want me
to tell the story or did you want to
just talk yeah
because if you just want to talk go
ahead I'll stop dude go ahead you know
what I could leave you record this
exactly yeah exactly cool
um but there's a number of things you
can do you could do the oops button yep
uh you can
you can like wait till you're all done
and then come come correct with the
person be like look I don't know if
you're doing that on purpose but you
kept interrupting me and that's like it
was driving me crazy that's hilarious
you know to be like talking and talking
they keep interrupting you and finishing
you talking and by the time you're done
and they go like this come here sit down
so in that conversation
I was trying to get some points across
uh you asked some questions that I was
already going to answer you'll also
interrupted with stuff that you thought
I was gonna say turns out I wasn't going
to say that stuff some of the stuff you
got right but it just made the general
conversation take just way longer you do
that I don't know if you do that and I'm
just letting you know so I'll catch you
later but there's a middle tier as well
what there's the innocent tier then
there's the really truly terrible you
said there's the three tiers right yeah
but then there's a second tier oh the
the lowest most innocent tier is tier
one and that's just like asking
questions before it's the gig is up yes
The Jig Is up okay the worst most
terrible is have you said this yet
what you have you said this no okay so
you I'm so I'm having trouble
understanding what the two that you've
said are so far okay the first one that
I said yes was the worst one that's the
third one okay okay so that should be
the top one it it's hard to it's hard to
the worst one should be number one no no
because it's tier one tier two tier
three okay okay all right so so tier one
is the least bad and it's the
interruption and it's the innocent one
asking questions yeah yeah tier tier
three is the worst tier three is the
worst and tier three is the one where
you start the person who interrupts you
starts saying what they think you're
saying but they're wrong wrong right
like I just like you just do it yeah but
so and then what's two two what's the
middle two it's just like uh
is just it's it's like it's half
innocent because they they are into it
but they like they keep trying to say
things that that it reminds them of
about themselves oh that's horrible yeah
it's terrible yeah but it's not as bad
as the the top yeah okay but that's tier
two those are the tears of terrorists
have you have stepping on hot calls
so did you um so did you think of this
before you just thought of this now that
you had the three tiers thing yeah well
that's amazing good job dude way to
think on the Fly thank you all right
cool well there you go then and uh yeah
I see it just get yourself a noobs
putting a chrysalia.com your own [__] so
hard Anthony put a thing an image of it
right here oh that's one you get a
chrysler.com okay he gets it okay okay
cool um
just a quick advice question for you I
love them yeah so we have two very close
friends
that went to Thailand two years ago
never came back and after they came back
they told us you guys should come next
time
they're like our best friends
and recently we found out that they have
already booked their flights to Thailand
including some of our friends in like
our close Circle have already booked
their flights and we have not heard
nothing about it we have talked to them
and they have not mentioned it they seem
totally fine they're not mad at us or
anything we're exchanging gifts with our
kids whoa yeah so we have no clue what's
going on oh it's in three months we want
to go to Thailand but we don't feel like
we're truly invited and haven't heard
anything for two years so we haven't
really been saving up
so
uh what do we do it's been two years any
advice
I don't know what was the two years
thing Chris that that two years ago they
went and they said you should come next
time oh right I think just plain and
simple be like wait you're going to
Thailand and they're going too like wait
yeah we all gonna go yeah and that you
don't have to act like an [__] though
just be like wait I actually thought
we're all gonna go we were excited about
that yeah that's not like a way you
don't you don't make people feel bad
doing that if you do that's a byproduct
of just actually wondering this is a
horror movie what is it this is it's
gonna be a horror movie you know oh when
they go to time yeah it's going to be
called like the uninvited guests or
something and like you get there and
they're gonna and you're they're gonna
murder you you know what I mean uh I
think I mean this sounds like a horror
movie it's like well we didn't and then
we you know and it would be about a
Danish guy you know what I mean and it
would be half an English half and
whatever they [__] speak over there
wow you know uh what do they speak
Danish hi no Danish I'm saying yeah
Danish okay
um
uh no but I you you go like this you say
hey
um just want to know all good I'm a big
because you know me and I've said this
before I'm a big proponent and you say
this of not everybody needs to always be
hanging out with all the friends all the
time I get it but
um you I just don't want you to think we
don't want to go to Thailand and I don't
know if it's on us to say hey we want to
come but you did mention it a while ago
and if it's a thing that you're gonna do
with those people all good but just let
us know because we're down
I think that's what you that's what I
would do and then if they're like Oh
They'll probably be like Oh Come yeah I
can't imagine well it definitely will
but here's the other thing you don't
want them to do like exactly [__] all
right yeah come
on exactly they don't want you to
exactly so that's why you don't so what
do you do do it as many in as many words
as you just said ah I'm the king of
words all you do is say what I uh in
fact what I said is the best okay we'll
say it again right so it's you're just
like Trump hey
something like
oh you're going to Thailand and wait
you're all going to Thailand I I thought
we were all including us yeah yours wow
sorry wow this requires the Thailand
being coming up somehow
yours yeah yeah yeah you bring it up no
you bring it out you go like this ah man
it's crazy all over the world man you
guys ever think of Thailand by the way
uh I heard you going
um that's fine did you want us to come
made that whole comment I'm not saying
all that
just bring it up out of it like that
holy [__] you're invited to everywhere I
go by the way who cares just bring it up
out of the blue it's on your mind you
know
yeah Thailand oh wait I heard you guys
are all going to time like we want to go
too oh dude that's the way to do it you
know what you do you get taboo and you
pick the card where you can say
everything but Thailand
how do you rig it well you just what oh
um okay so uh all our friends are going
and we're not invited right all right
yeah but how do you rig it is it the
logistics of that you you [__] put up
the car you set the cards up you know
what I mean all our friends no no no and
all the friends are there and they're
like uh and they go oh you didn't get it
it's Thailand so so now that we're
talking about it what's up with that so
we were supposed to go so I just don't
know if you guys all know but we were
invited first okay because two years ago
they said you should go next time and
what the [__] now everybody's all what
is this all about dude everybody's going
we're not um
I come up with great ways dude
that's so roundabout
it requires you have to buy the game
Taboo first of all everyone has taboo
the card Thailand might not even exist
you have to make your own card you make
your own card you'd be like you know
what dude hey guys so I will play Taboo
I'm getting rid of these cards I made my
own cards I just have like five of them
and be Thailand be one of them two of
them two of them
and then they do it again and they say
is Thailand again they say yeah and
actually that reminds me there's more I
want to talk about that yeah
taboo's fun dude yeah taboo is the game
we were playing when Dad said look at
this yeah yeah yeah
those are those the days huh yeah those
were that was the day
guys let's take a break because this
episode is brought to you by betterhelp
um look when I feel like I'm my best
self
uh I operate better my mental is better
I'm in a better mood the reason I get
there is because of therapy definitely
when I'm open and honest with my
therapist
um
otherwise I can't operate in that way uh
when you're at your best and I can
certainly say when I'm I'm at my best I
do great things but you can do great
things too uh sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
like you're not showing up the way that
you want to trust me I get it better
help can help working with a therapist
can get you closer to the best version
of you because when you feel empowered
you're more prepared to take on
everything that life throws at you all
right if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try and you never have
especially better help is awesome better
help is great because you don't have to
go anywhere they just match you with a
therapist after you fill out a brief
questionnaire and you can just uh you
can just start talking and it's amazing
what this does it's convenient flexible
affordable and it's entirely online if
you don't like the therapist they set
you up with yeah you can just get it try
a different one right away no additional
charge whatsoever right so uh it really
it really takes the oh I don't want to
get up and do this out of it yep you
need to therapy you maintain your car
you you know you need to maintain your
brain and better help is a good way to
do that if you want to live a more
empowered life therapy can help you
uh help you there visit betterhelp.com
Lifeline today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash Lifeline thanks hey
whoa whoa the NFL playoff action
continues we are one step closer to
Super Bowl 57 and for the NFL divisional
round check out DraftKings Sportsbook I
know I am it's an official sports
betting partner of the NFL new customers
can bet just five dollars and guess what
guess how many free bets you get
instantly two hundred dollars
200 in free bets we're just spending
five dollars plus all new and existing
customers can take a shot at an even
bigger payout with DraftKings stepped up
same game parlays boost your NFL
winnings with each leg you add up to 100
percent Matt who you got your eye on I
got my Ford later today the Cowboys are
going up against my 49ers I can never
root for the Cowboys because they're the
Cowboys and I got my 49ers going all the
way so the 49ers
excite me okay well they excite you
that's great so download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app and use code Lifeline new
customers can bet five dollars on the
NFL divisional round and get 200 and
free bets instantly only at DraftKings
Sportsbook with code Lifeline minimum
age and eligibility restrictions apply
see show notes for details
same guys up Chris and Matt loving the
podcast
takes apart calculators and and like
mixes them all up and then figures out
how to put them back together and then
they work even better than they did
look at him like what in your childhood
makes you think that that's that guy you
know what I mean I don't know you must
have seen somebody like that
you know and I think that there's some
trauma there so go go
Steve Alpert start it over yeah
also loves his mom and so nice to her
uh Chris I saw you in Boston The Late
Show so good so the first one was better
thank you with my girlfriend
and this is kind of what my question
involves so
I've been dating this girl for about six
seven months right and I'm in school and
she's got a calculator we're both going
to study abroad next semester what
brought her yesterday
and she's gonna be in Europe and I'm
gonna be in New Zealand now we both want
to make this relationship work
so how do you guys recommend I go about
this like considering time zones oh my
God considering how far we're going to
be we're probably not going to see each
other for like six months
um but we really want to make it work
and I really like this girl but so how
do you guys recommend I go about this
thanks dude let me just let me just tell
you something here this is so
[__] and I will tell you
you think six months is the doable no it
let me just tell you this dude okay okay
I'll shut up I'll stop interrupting I'll
stop being in tier two Okay so
women
change their it doesn't take six months
for them to um you know and maybe and
these six months I've
it's one day bro what are you saying
they go like this they're it's three
months in they're really missing the
[__] out of the guy yeah they're missing
the [__] out of him his girlfriend okay
oh man I miss him thinking about him
every day
one day yeah one of the days yeah like
a dog runs by yeah and goes to the a
dude that owns the dog and he's like oh
hey what's up yeah and she's like oh
that's a cool dog he's like oh that's
hilarious
um anyway uh cool not hilarious but okay
yeah
then that [__]
dude okay dude this is when you're being
the most steeper right now in the
history of the world because one time I
had I had a girlfriend okay yeah and and
we were things were going great
oh wow okay things were going you're
being serious right now yeah oh we're
going crazy yeah yeah but we all learn
from our experiences okay yeah so by the
way this has happened to me multiple
times so we have we we we were it was
great she goes like this hey going to
Paris and I say huh she says yeah going
to Paris I was like what are you talking
about we've been together for two years
she's like I'm just gonna take a trip
and I go I say all right well when she's
like I'm gonna go in like three weeks I
said well why didn't you tell what's you
she's hired about the ticket I said what
the [__] and she's like I knew if I if I
didn't do it right then I wouldn't do it
and I say okay uh well that's so weird
though yeah it is weird
goes to Paris
doesn't meet someone uh-huh
comes back from Paris says it's over
dude she was there for a week
she didn't even meet someone okay she
came back started dating someone in L.A
it takes one day all I gotta do is see
something like a dog run by okay but
no
okay more six weeks two days is the same
so you're saying you're putting in this
guy's head one day it's gonna be one
month she's gonna leave him it's going
to be like a [__] tennis racket to
your face that's not at all my
experience at all and frankly I don't
even hear that happening ever
to be twice I don't even I only know if
it happened to you once without Capital
Town remember yeah and then another that
was one one that even mentioned okay
well anyway I I have a completely
different uh
opinion on the matter was El Capitano
it's equally Bleak but it's not okay
similar to yours at all six months when
you're really in love with somebody
when you're thinking about the prospect
of spending six months apart sounds so
doable and so straightforward and so
manageable okay it isn't it's not it's
so [__] hardened it feels like six
years it's the hardest thing in the
world so I think
instead of I mean you're he seems so
young they're in school did he say how
old he is the younger the worse I know
that's why I'm 50. we're going to die in
20 years anyway they might be better off
keeping it loose and saying we want to
be together after these six months then
like really putting it on themselves
pressuring themselves to make sure it it
works out throughout the six months I'm
not saying like go with God for six
months I'll see you on the other side
I'm saying we love each other we want to
make it work but more than anything we
want to make sure that in six months
we're back where we want to be with each
other let me just tell you something
dude okay
I understand what you're saying so what
about the guide also no I know but
listen dude they're going to they should
by the way reverse the places they're
going to
she's going to [__] Britain where the
chicks are ugly but the dudes are like
how are you yes it's nice to be
beautiful where in England yeah where
are they dude in London they're not
okay anyway keep going and then the dupe
okay fine there are some hot women in in
in in in in Britain but bro the dudes
though
they all got [__] up teeth but the
dudes that's part of it they're ugly but
the women it's like yeah I got [__] up
teeth but with the dudes it's like you
know it's part of my [__] thing ain't
it right yeah and so and then and so
you're gonna be letting her go there for
six months she's gonna meet some dude
named Hugh or Nigel right and then he's
going to New Zealand where the chicks
are just all tatted up and just ready
wait do we know how's it going yeah
he just said Europe right he didn't say
where she's going specifically honestly
any place but Britain is even worse
France Spain worse in what way like
she's gonna cheat on him yeah dude the
dudes are [__] going going
they should both concede the fact that
cheating is probably going to happen for
both of them they're young
and like
just just look here's what you should do
go into it saying we love each other we
want to make sure it works on the other
side we don't want to make [__] it up
while we're apart so like
let's keep each other in one another's
Hearts but know that whatever one of us
does here or there or whoever the [__]
it's it's we're gonna have to be okay
with it when we come back here because
the last thing you want to do is really
put pressure on yourselves and then one
of you is faithful and then the other
one isn't and then by the time the six
months are up and everybody's back the
truth comes out everything's [__] up
get a wig
be her go to Britain she cut her hair
you know
the worst movie the worst movie premise
ever
for no reason like there's no not even a
reason to do it go to New Zealand
because the dudes in New Zealand are not
good looking and the and the chicks in
[__] Britain I mean the dude's got a
leg up on them do you know what I'm
saying otherwise you're gonna go to
Britain dude I swear to God eight days
she's gonna be
what's up
Matt are you saying what's that song
again uh
am I saying what are you saying don't
ask don't tell no I'm not I'm not I'm
just saying be loose with each other
because if you're too tight it's easier
to break like let
yourselves remain in love give
yourselves a chance but let each other
breathe because the more suffocating one
one is or the other is you're just gonna
end up pushing the person away or one
one person does make a mistake or slip
up or whatever the pressure's gonna be
that much more like
yeah impossible to overcome
music play the song that goes what's up
I don't like any of this
wasn't it got it wrong
I ain't no [__]
[Music]
that's so many songs at once I got I got
I got one that's uh MLP okay I don't
know that what I forget what it is and
you know we played in this podcast
before
yeah I know okay so then you should know
so no so he knows is what he's saying he
said he doesn't know you're the one who
played it I know because I asked Mako
the first time what it was and he told
me and now he's saying he doesn't know
which is [__]
there we go dude
why were you holding out on me dude he
didn't know Anthony knew I know why was
he holding out on me he looked it up
what did you Google
some cut dude
dude it's got some cut I'll tell you
eight days in Britain dude
I don't know how are you that's nice to
meet you oh wow look at that wow nice
after that oh you got another glass on
your duck yeah I mean oh that's really
nice isn't it
that's happening for sweat entirely too
long let me see the backside there oh
wow isn't that nice I can put my drink
down on it yeah come here put a Guinness
sound on here wow
okay
stop
anyway uh good luck to you but that
shit's so hard long distance especially
when you're young is so [__] hard
dude I've done it did it failed at it
done it again after that failed at it
never succeeded at it bing bong bing
a the year of the big Hmong I mean it's
hard yeah but here's the thing it's
they're being an end already it being
six months makes it at least possible so
there is
hope I guess you could say but
that shit's hard
yeah all right cool all right next one
hey doormat and Christopher the worst
you expect you guys were arguing amongst
yourselves which name was the best door
mat and
then you said the worst name for a guy
Keith is Bruce yeah that's you no so I
was named after my grandpa Bruce I like
Bruce who died from leukemia okay so
thanks for crapping on both of our names
no problem dude but that's not why I'm
sending this no problem I would like
some advice on the most creative or
memorable way to quit
not in a mean way but you just want it
to be creative
and I've been at the same job for about
11 years wow our same company doing this
doing my trade for 11 years and I really
like my boss but you know I think it's
just time to move on and
side note he watches this show
religiously oh boy sometimes we watch it
together at work
so I'm not sure how this is going to go
but it's hilarious I don't know what do
you think is the most creative way well
this memorable way to quit your job this
is hey hey boss Bruce is thinking about
quitting so why don't you have the
conversation Bruce is out no he's not
thinking about it he's done he's out hey
boss you're done
okay okay well yeah boss Bruce is done
Bruce doesn't want to work for you
anymore we're sorry
um but it's okay because you don't want
a guy that doesn't really want to be
there and he needs to do bigger and
better things right and he has no hard
feelings he's not mad he's not mad he
doesn't want to make a scene doesn't
want to make you feel bad it's time to
move on his name is Bruce uh
uh this is the way well Bruce will let
you know
that this is happening or producers will
let you know follow up with you so you
can watch this episode with your boss
right and he will learn this way yeah
hey Bruce's boss dude no no he doesn't
want to do in a mean way he said no no
for me but I know but still it's like
let's be on everybody's side right
because this is Bruce's face right now
no he knows he knows it's coming no but
he he saw the he's watching Lifeline
he's going to why is he doing that
because he's watching it with the guy
but he knows why are you acting confused
why did you he's like why are You The
Boss yeah why didn't you just oh the
boss is doing yeah dude you didn't say
that he said Bruce was doing that the
boss was doing that I said he said Bruce
okay well I'm a boss
um yeah
yeah that should go over really well
well I mean look dude there's no easy
way really to quit you want to quit you
want to quit 11 years of this [__] you
know obviously you've been thinking
about it so it's all good man and you
know you could still remain friends you
can still watch your show why don't you
dude watch the next episode together in
the next year full of episodes right
right there you go you know so yeah dude
we're with you buddy and we're sorry and
Bruce I don't think is the worst name
you know what and I'm not just saying
this because I got called out
I I agree that Bruce is not the one
Bruce is a cool name yeah Bruce Willis
kind of made it popular
um okay Bruce is not that bad it's true
I don't know why I even said that we're
just making jokes you know we have fun
yeah yeah I think wanker is the worst
name what's up Chris and Matt huge fan
of the podcast wrapping that spin move
mentality hoodie
uh I just wanted to ask y'all for a
little bit of advice I work for a retail
job right now
and I work with a lot of really cool
people we're all in a group chat we all
try to get together on our off days it's
awesome and
um play softball and basketball and
stuff like that but whenever I hang out
with them I always find myself being
really awkward and being really
to myself and saying things that like I
think back later and I'm like oh why did
I say that and stuff like that
and it makes you know I'm I'm I find
myself awkward to a point where I kind
of don't want to hang out with them even
though I enjoy I enjoy them all they're
all really cool people and I enjoy get
getting out there playing softball or
whatever we're doing but I I find myself
so odd like being so awkward I don't
want to go out there and hang out with
them because I don't want them not to
like me you know what I'm saying yeah so
I just wanted to know if y'all have any
advice on that I I'd really appreciate
it uh I'm normally a really you know
funny and outlandish pretty loud dude I
just found myself with them being real
real awkward and contempt I'm not really
sure why uh any advice man yeah I'd
appreciate fulfilling prophecy man
that's what happens you got your own hoe
or you dug yourself in it and now you
can't get out the truth is
each time for two things each time you
hang out with them
is its own time once it's done flush it
down the toilet it's over nobody else is
still thinking about the weird thing you
did yeah nobody else is thinking about
you in a good way I mean as much as you
think it's like I wish I could [__] all
your wives anyway as much as you think
it was dumb of you to say a thing and
how it was like it's festering for you
that's not what's happening with them
first of all second of all don't let it
accumulate otherwise like Chris said it
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy the
more you think ah [__] I shouldn't have
said that the more likely you are to
have it happen again where you say oh
[__] that was a dumb thing to say or
whatever just like let it all go what's
done is done next time you hang out with
them this is the new you and guess what
if you do something that's awkward
who the [__] cares do it again yes it's
not gonna happen the more the less
pressure you put on yourself to not be
awkward the less awkward you will be
also it's that shame that's speaking to
you dude it's your oh [__] I wasn't good
enough I wasn't there dude I have the
tapes I play in my head too ever since
childhood you are good enough and you're
[__] it's like that what's that
Stuart Smalley I'm good enough I'm smart
enough and doggone people like me you
know what for real and I have trouble
with this but affirmations man you look
in the mirror you look in your eyes and
you say I'm worthy of friendship try to
do that watch how [__] hard it is
inside you watch your heart do a twist
and turn it's [__] hard do that until
it doesn't feel weird anymore and that
will help for real and I'm not a big
affirmations guy I do say affirmations
you know I was getting a massage the
other day I was so uncomfortable I
couldn't [__] enjoy it and face down
I just started saying I'm worthy of I'm
I'm worthy of love people like me I'm
good and dude I got out of that [__] man
and your masseuse was like what well I
mouthed it oh oh I did it just like I
was Face Down in the Hole so weird for a
masseuse okay I am okay like that kind
of [__] yeah that's very strange but it
helps though they say it helps it's like
fake smiling then turns into a real they
do say that helps yeah so I try to do
that and so do that or look in your own
eyes and say I'm a good friend that's
not the issue at hand though no but it
but but you don't want to fix the
symptom you want to hit the root of the
problem just be like I'm not awkward if
you need him to do that no but no one's
paying as much attention to me
it's deeper than that as I am it's
deeper that the awkwardness is the
symptom you want to get the root problem
you want to go I am okay look in your
eyes I am a good friend I deserve
friendship look in your own eyes and do
that [__] watch your heart do
somersaults until it doesn't and then
you get into this attitude where you're
like you know what [__] it [__] it man
I'm me and I have trouble with it myself
I really do I have trouble with it
myself I have a deep need of acceptance
but you know sometimes with different
groups of friends it's different and
with this group of friends that says
this is your [__] cross to bear but
you got this bro we can tell you a good
guy and by the way they don't like you
for the reasons why you think they like
you they like you because you're you
and we can tell I bet they don't even
think you're awkward David they probably
don't or they do in a fun way or they
like it you know what I mean like own it
all this is you this is okay you are
okay and do those [__] affirmations
in the mirror man and watch your heart
do a somersault stop saying that okay
but a specific thing
yeah so that's good whoa next one there
we go dude a couple years ago wow how's
it going boys big fan of the podcast
thank you a fan of the both of you uh me
and my girlfriend watch Lifeline every
week
I've been watching congratulations for
years my favorite episodes or when you'd
have your brother your dad on oh nice
always the best
so I love Lifeline thank you you guys
for entertaining us thank you so I've
got a question it's a question you guys
have received
kind of similar uh
my co-worker stinks really bad like cat
piss most of the time cat pissed
sometimes just like pure
stench I've I've learned how to describe
should I just say you smell like [__]
I don't know should I go to my manager
uh
that's so Happy's Batman the advice
would be greatly appreciated thank you
so I actually have experienced someone
smelling my cat piss in my life and it's
it's [__] a tragedy
now in my experience the person was
smelling like catfish because of their
diet
they changed their diet and whatever
they were doing was
the reason was responsible for their
campus what were they eating the cat
piss and onions no they became vegan and
that was what made them smell like
Cactus whoa and then they started eating
meat no I I stopped being around that
person because they smelled like catfish
but you said they oh they changed their
diet too do that oh yeah yeah yeah whoa
yeah it was terrible
um for that person I'm not saying vegans
were you dating or was it a friend
dating or a friend or what yeah I was
dating okay so
um that's a little different than
workplace [__] you gotta be careful well
yeah you can't also you can't even know
if it's a diet thing because no no but
what I'm saying is you got to be careful
about telling them they smell like [__]
because you can get if you're their
[__] boss or something yeah they
could get sued so like write a note on a
paper airplane make sure the paper
airplane curves the right way so like
say your co-workers here's the person
you wanted to go you throw it over there
and it goes so it looks like it came
from over there yeah but you're over
here what me she's like these are the
kinds that curve
yeah I I that's a rough [__] thing
man
um people sent that you can't escape
from is a real problem
because oh here's the other thing too I
don't know what percentage but I bet
it's high they can't fix it right maybe
you know like I said maybe it's a diet
thing I haven't really been around
people that smell bad all that much to
be honest oh I I have dude
I mean at meet and greets when I do my
meet and greets sometimes are people
that come up and I'm like oh wow
interesting oh oh you're just a you just
smell horrible yeah you know is it okay
you haven't been around a lot of people
that smell bad no and I have geez really
I really haven't you're lucky huh yeah
and I always smell pretty damn good and
so do you yeah well
I think it's also
and I firmly believe this
there are probably many people in that
person's life who he says smells like
campus that don't smell the cat piss
thing people respond to chemical people
so vastly different and they say that if
you find somebody that you love their
smell that you will you will have good
babies with them
I made that up but I feel like I feel
like um that's a good baby like like uh
healthy oh like um like chemically that
you're supposed to be with that person
that's what I think
I think that because you've ever been
around what you said is [__] stupid
okay well does that make sense but you
don't have any science that backs up
what you're saying and then I'm not
saying anything I'm just commenting on
what you said you just made up a thing
wow completely made it up do you think
that sounds good and you said the result
is good babies don't you think that
sounds good don't you think it sounds
probably right
chemically you're supposed to be with
the person you want to be with so you're
supposed to be the person to to push the
human race as as as far as you can you
want to mate with people who smell good
with each other right well that's
probably what I believe in this is
backed up by science the people we are
attracted to whether we realize it or
not
what one of the things we're primarily
attracted by is sent even if we're not
recognizing yeah for sure definitely oh
definitely so they trick you with
shampoos though you know you got to get
beyond that no but we know what's what
do we Yeah because sometimes you just
smell herbalescence and you're like I'm
in love yeah but you get on you get
underneath it that's you do you're
saying pheromones yeah I think we are
way better at that than you ever been I
think we realized you ever been with
somebody that their breath is just
intoxicating
uh no but I've been with someone whose
breath smells like rat poison okay well
and and and tastes like rat poison when
you kiss them oh God [__] me too
no I have you have yeah but but I've
also been with people whose breath are
intoxicating
breath isn't dark yeah I'm just like I
can't get enough of it the Kristen is
that way she always has yeah Christian
is that way good breath
no uh yeah now I guess maybe that's just
for me I don't know that's what I feel
like maybe someone else because
sometimes you've been with with people
who have bad breath and then they start
dating people and you're like
exactly you know they come out talking
about the first point I was making right
right what's terrible yeah what smells
like Happ is to one person might smell
like [__] roses to another on your
team have you ever uh dated someone that
you actually love their smell for
however long in general and then
something happens no you suddenly detest
there's like a brain injury
no like they just they become vegan oh
no okay well that happened to me wow
that's crazy and it was a Devastation
yeah that's like another yeah oh wow
okay
well hope it was worth it but they
weren't eating meat go ahead next one
doubt it Shaggy a guy from Scooby-Doo
I'm gay Canadian
man Chris stop talking about what's
going on I'm pretty excited to talk to
you guys huge fan of you Chris
I have a dilemma okay
um I've got some friends who I love uh
but lately it's been really hard to hang
out with them because they always have
to be the wokest person in the room I
like to you know mess around and hang
out and have fun and we all know what
our opinions are on certain subjects but
for some reason they always feel like
they have to
do a little comment and be like look how
woke I am look how much better I am than
you and it really makes my stomach hurt
and I don't like being around people who
try to act like they're better than
other people and I just want to hang out
and it's really driving me crazy and we
kind of don't like the certain friend
group anymore because it just feels like
everyone's afraid to talk to each other
and they don't feel like real friends
they feel like
people were trying to impress so I don't
know if you guys have that if you have a
group that you tried forcing yourselves
to hang out with at any points and
because I have a hard time not being
friends with people anymore so just let
me know like cutting them out yeah
that's what he means yeah I I just it's
just you need new friends that's awful
that is so awful if they just always
sorry I was saving Humanity all right
thank you I thought I thought Marco
paused it yeah no he didn't
um
yeah dude that's awful man I just I you
need new friends that they're not going
because you can't be woke enough so
they're all gonna start [__] sword
fighting eventually I mean it's just
said that it's just one group of them
yeah it's not all of his friends right
yeah yeah but you need new friends well
maybe he doesn't need new phone okay
well then you need to cut them out yeah
right yeah I just yeah and he said we
probably means him and his girlfriend
yeah I really or he's got multiple
organizers yeah yeah true or he's gay
and it's his partner but either way you
got somebody that backs you up or trans
and goes by them and he's referring to
himself as we yeah I don't know you know
it could be any right it could be him
and the rest of the cast of Scooby Doo I
really want to know what he means woke
in what context like does it matter
it could it can yeah sure uh I I wonder
how much I've never had friends that are
as he's saying so woke it like distracts
from
the hang or something that sounds like
you're hanging out with some like
[__] tyrants or something well that's
yeah I mean a lot of work people are
like that yeah no I know but if it's
getting to a point where it's that bad I
can't even that's why I wanted context I
wish I knew what I wonder what he maybe
on the next live episode we do he could
call in because like I wonder really
what the [__] he's talking about with uh
like if they're like oh I mean look if
he's walking around saying [__] it
saying racial slaves that's what I'm
saying yeah it's like you know bro you
gotta [__] chill exactly right but if
he's like yeah so you know it's funny uh
or if he's just like I like to show
whatever the [__] and they're like well
that show actually is problematic
because of whatever right then you're
like all right you know yeah yeah you
know I'm just trying to chill you guys
gonna judge me when you got your own
skeletons in your closet probably wow
but I mean they you know everyone has
[__] so it's like
um
yeah it I don't know what to do so small
how he wrote it you don't know what to
do
is that what you're saying yeah I'm
saying I don't know what to do for him
okay well that's a weird way to say that
what did I say you said I don't know
what to do yeah I don't know what to do
for you oh just [__] don't hang out
with those people I guess so I mean is
it cut and dry so but then he's like is
a problem
ending get better at that
oh I mean really a hardcore man I mean
like I'll get better at that because
that's a skill we all need you can't
what if you had what if you had a group
of friends that was [__] just all the
time you loved them and then but
suddenly all of a sudden all of them
started shooting heroin into their arm
not even realize I was gone because
they'd be so doped up would you ever
would you have a hard time mixing them
no but what is this I would be like guys
you do too much heroin I gotta go and
they would be like this no you would I'm
saying as a hypothetical to the guy
who's here to answer the question yeah
he would be able to be like oh what the
[__] and get out of there that's a way
more extreme example and a way more
harmful example but like
maybe just realize what you've said
which is that you [__] don't like
these people anymore yeah
and they're not they don't make you feel
good or whatever they make you feel
tense I think is what he was getting at
yeah uh then don't hang out with him
dude yeah and if it's hard
to next people out of your life like
it's hard for everybody to do that but
that's a skill you need true so just get
to practicing on these [__] Yeah so
basically just don't hang out with those
people anymore and then also has it
happened to you has what have you had to
been like I can't hang out with these
people anymore oh yeah yeah for a number
of reasons not for that reason right
right yeah yeah definitely yeah I have
to smelling like campus have you ever
had to do it with a whole group of
people
he's talking about a group of people
yeah he is um because I've cut people
out of my life
kinda it's usually like the entry point
is one really good friend and then the
group is like yeah people I know through
that right right right yeah so yeah kind
of yeah all right well look you know oh
all power you know more power to you we
hope you get through it uh Seattle I'll
see you tonight chrisley.com get tickets
uh Jacksonville Lakeland and Daytona
I'll be there next weekend Sugarland
Texas and San Antonio I'll be there the
next weekend and then later on in
February I'll be in New York City Rhode
Island Providence Rhode Island and
um uh Chicago thank you very much uh if
you want uh go to chrisley.com for
tickets you want one-on-one advice
sessions with my brother Mr Diggy out of
a hole mattelia.com if you have a
question click the link in the
description below or go to watch
lifeline.com and you can get the merch
like the guy was wearing spin movement
mentality sweater or hoodie at
lifelinemerch.com I really like that
hoodie yeah it's good I love it at first
but it really [__] grows on you and
that's what good March does it grows on
you just like this podcast and
it's comfortable as [__] yep okay so
guys
leave a comment bump up the algorithm
make sure you're subscribed and if
you're not subscribed to super good
[Music]